oh really had to go out of the house I
was glad you came out I appreciate it
for we'll go check this girl out man she
is fine she I really
amen I am going to go to the bathroom
look at it seeing it you know what I've
told myself this morning I wasn't gonna
fall in love you went and made me break
my only rule I'm gonna take that right
quick I am going to take that I'm going
to use that okay
[Laughter]
got her number huh yeah Cheyenne though
is that her name yes she was like that's
like that's the girl I was talking about
oh snap are you serious I'm sorry no
thing I forget it's plenty high seas
does you don't touch girls
I'm not a sports man but I mean you
could touch down later if you know what
I'm saying I'm I'm being stupid
but for real though just give me a
number whatever thank you girl I'm gonna
take that how did you get over here so
fast
nothing it just seemed like you damn
that reporter is smokin hot
I love you I'm sorry I was out I was
looking at other women tonight but you
are all there is I love you
[Music]
[Music]